we have breaking news from Washington
where reports say Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosenstein is on his way out
is the number-two man at the Justice
Department he's either resigning or
being fired we've heard both three days
after he reportedly offered to wiretap
President Trump last year following the
firing of FBI director James Comey Paula
Reed is here with the significance of
this mood paula of this move rather
Paula what can you tell us well as you
just said sources have confirmed to me
that rod Rosen Stein is on his way to
the White House where he expects to be
fired nur that our reports out there
that he's going to offer his resignation
but I have not confirmed that inside the
Justice Department so the question is
whether or not this will happen if you
will either resign or actually be fired
and as you said this comes just days
after reports that he suggested
wiretapping the president or trying to
use the 25th amendment to oust him but
my reporting I talked to about half a
dozen sources on Friday from people who
were in the room during this meeting
last year and they all said yes he
mentioned wiretapping the president but
he was joking he said it sarcastically
and not one clearly a joke they said yes
it was clearly a joke and if you ever
talk to the Deputy Attorney General he
makes a lot of jokes especially when
talking about tense or important
subjects now the other thing is I didn't
talk to a single source who ever
remembered him suggesting anything about
using the 25th amendment to ask the
president and I think anyone should be
suspect of the idea that Attorney
General Jeff Sessions would have
supported any effort to try to get 2/3
of Congress to Austin so I think there's
a lot of skepticism about those reports
rod Rosenstein is essentially in charge
of the Russia investigation of the Bob
Muller Special Counsel what happens if
frozen Stein leaves if Rosen Stein
leaves the investigation will go to null
friends Cisco here's the Solicitor
General there is a line of succession
after Justice Department and right now
it's not just that you get a new job you
also get a new responsibility so no
Francisco would now be the one
overseeing the Special Counsel
investigation does it matter whether he
resigns or is fired I don't really think
it does either way he's gone and the big
question is well now who is overseeing
the Special Counsel investigation to
whom does Robert Muller have to go to
approve any and everything he does and
they're also going to be the person that
will have the ultimate decision over
what to do with Special Counsel Robert
Muller's final report do you stick it in
a drawer and do nothing do you pass it
off to
Congress do you make it public it's a
huge job and also does an oil francisco
fire muller as some people have
suggested the president might want and
we have to end it rosin stein and said
he wouldn't unless he had cause so
that's still now an open question -
exactly I've asked know that a few times
when I've seen him and he refused to
answer all right
probably still well Paula thank you